doesn't it ever wake you up in the  middle of the night a feeling that  someday they'll come for you and your  children I feel a great swirl of pity  for the poor soul that comes to my  school looking for trouble  some believe that the first mutant was  born thousands of years ago he was some  kind of God and he's gonna rise again  you are all my children that you lost  because you follow blind leaders  Oh mah God I'm here now he always had  four followers like the Four Horsemen of  the Apocalypse together we will cleanse  the earth to the strongest take  everything from them he means to destroy  this world billions of people killed  the world needs the x-men you're gonna  join them weren't you  I wanted me to get out of the house bar  right it's all of us against a god let's  go to war  forget everything you think you know  you're not students anymore  your x-men  thank you sir very sweet very full  ASA has ended ahead